oh hi welcome to game life it is
election day and that means it's time
for you to do your patriotic duty get
out of bed get out of the house walk
down the street and get in line wait
your turn patiently to buy halo 4 it's
the first halo game not produced by
Bungie the creator of the series but you
wouldn't know that from playing it halo
4 is getting rave reviews meaning that
fans of the series should rest easy it's
time to suit up in the Master Chief
armor once again this time the story's a
lot more personal for those of you who
want to know more about the man behind
the mask run halo 4 hits xbox 360 on
tuesday november six halo 4 is an xbox
360 exclusive now doesn't Sony need
something to answer that with on
PlayStation 3 yes and it's little big
planet karting no you might say this
doesn't exactly reach the same audience
but why try to compete if a gamer is
turned off by shooting aliens they might
love a mario kart style game in which
you can create your own tracks and
missions
littlebigplanet karting is out Tuesday
only on PlayStation 3 thrifty year
gamers might appreciate to budget-minded
collections also coming out on Tuesday
if you haven't gotten into the Mass
Effect series of sci-fi role-playing
games your chances now Mass Effect
trilogy comes to 360 today if you want
to play it on the PlayStation 3 you'll
have to wait until December fourth and
if you're a fan of the makers of grand
theft auto you'll want Rockstar Games
collection which contains GTA episodes
from liberty city red dead redemption
midnight club los angeles and my
personal favorites LA noir finally
nintendo fans are about to have a great
weekend on Sunday November 11 paper
mario sticker star arrives for nintendo
3ds this series of role-playing games
have always had hilarious writing clever
gameplay and an inventive world that
looks like it was cut out of
construction paper it's all here in this
3ds version and it all looks like a tiny
little shoebox diorama now in 3d now
remember paper mario sticker star is
coming out just one week before the Wii
U which means the Nintendo fans have
only seven days to get through this
adventure before the apocalypse happens
speaking of next week we'll see you that
I